I'm Alanna fish I'm a professor at the
University of Alberta and I'm also a
fellow of the Alberta machine
intelligence Institute and I'm gonna
follow in Jessica's footsteps in that
I'm not going to talk about exploration
of the out words but rather exploration
of the in words and how we know what we
know and how we could tell if a computer
knew something too so you've probably
interacted with Assyria or somebody like
Siri either on your phone or maybe you
have an Amazon Alexa in your house I
have had the experience of saying hey
Siri call my mom and she does actually
place a call to my mother but do you
think that Siri understands the concept
of mother do you think she understands
the concept of call even though she's a
phone I think she doesn't understand
what even call means and so I'm
interested in asking how did computers
understand meaning and language and how
could we tell if they understood what we
said so how do we test understanding so
if I was trying to test whether a person
understood what I was saying I would ask
them to do something and if they did the
right thing then I could say oh they
understand me but we've already decided
that that's not how we want to test Siri
Siri does what we asked her to do but we
still don't believe that she understands
us so let's think about how we test
students we test students every day and
we do things
ask them about things in their world
things that we've taught them to see if
they know what what they've learned and
so one thing that we can do to test
students about what what words mean is
to do an allergy test so hammer is to
nail as screwdriver is to screw very
good excellent work hammers to nails
screwdrivers to screw your right so this
tells us that you understand the
individual words and also the
relationships between the words and so
do you think we could get a computer to
do this task and so that's the first
thing I'm going to talk about today so
we're going to use in order to solve
analogies we're going to use computer
models of word meaning so computer
models of word meaning are built on the
fact that words that are similar are
used in similar ways so if we were to
look through all of the websites on the
internet and look for the word car and
the word truck they would probably also
both
be used in similar context they both be
used with the words gas drive door steer
etcetera and so that would tell us that
they have similar meaning and so what
computer models of weird meaning do is
to use that leverage that fact in order
to build models so we're going to
calculate statistics about the word
co-occurrence when two words occur
together and we're going to turn those
statistics into lists of numbers when
words have similar meaning they will
have similar lists so here I have I'm
representing the numbers with the color
blue and if it's more blue than it's a
larger number and so these two words car
and truck I've made a short list here
and because car and truck are similar
they have similar lists of numbers or
they're not exactly the same so we can
use this idea of lists of numbers in
order to tell if two words are similar
so hammer is two nail as screwdrivers to
screw now we need to use these lists of
numbers to actually perform the analogy
tasks so we're actually going to do is
literally do math on these lists of
numbers so we're gonna take the this
four nail and subtract the list four
hammer and add the list or screwdriver
just element by element and that gives
us a new vector it turns out that sorry
new list of numbers and that new list of
numbers tends to be close to the correct
answer to analogy task so this
hypothetical list of numbers is close to
the current statistics we see for the
word screw so let's test our computer
model we're going to do the analogy test
where we choose from five options and so
if we were a randomly guessing if you
didn't know what you were doing you
would get 20% on this particular test so
the average US College applicant gets
57% so better than better than guessing
and it turns out these word lists that I
just told you about actually do almost
as well as the u.s. college applicants
so 56% so do computers understand
language are you convinced so I think
you would you would be it would be right
for you to still be skeptical I am also
still skeptical so I think we both can
agree that computers do not understand
the meaning of words even though we've
performed these analogy tests as well as
us high school and high school students
so let's go right to the source half of
my work is also on brain imaging and
studying what language looks like in the
so let's see what word meaning looks
like in the brain so the way we're gonna
do this
remember our computer models are just
lists of numbers turns out that brain
images are also just lists of numbers so
for a particular area the list of
numbers represents how much activity
there is in that area so in both cases
we just have lists of numbers and we can
tell how similar the list of numbers are
and we can use that in order to compare
the two sources of information so
essentially what we're gonna do is take
pairs of concepts so things like dog and
cat car and truck and we're gonna
compare how similar they are in using
the list of numbers from brains and
using the list of numbers from computer
models and so we would like to rank
these lists of pairs and check if the
ranking is similar across their two data
sources and if it's similar then we
would say that computers understand
things in the same way that the brain
does so this is your brain on the top is
the left high side of your brain and the
bottom is right and I'm highlighting
here just the areas of the brain that
are known to be involved in language
processing so I just want you to
remember that there's a there's a few
little spots here and most of them are
on the right on the left-hand side and
so now I'm the next slide I'm going to
show you essentially the results from
comparing a computer model of meaning to
a human brain and so here we're going to
be coloring the brain with these colors
that represent how correlated those
rankings are so if it's red or yellow
it's very correlated and if it's more of
a blue than it's less correlated and if
it's gray then it's not significant
there's no significant relationship
between the computer model and the brain
so here the first thing that notices
there's nothing that's gray which is
remarkable and interesting and not
something that was known before this
research was started we thought language
was really relegated to these one pieces
but it turns out that language meaning
is all over your brain you understand
language with your entire brain we also
see the same pattern of some more red
and yellow on the left hand side but we
see language meaning all over the brain
and this shows up in other studies too
so this is brain images captured while
people listen to podcasts and so here we
see if anything is black that mean
it's also not significantly related to
the computer model of meaning but here
we see lots of parts of the brain are
not black and that shows us that this
computer model of meaning is related to
how your brain registers meaning as
you're listening to a podcast so parts
of our brains do represent meaning in
the same way that computers do so
computers think like us are you
convinced I again I think you're right
to remain skeptical but it's interesting
to think about what it would take to
convince you that a computer understood
language thank you very much
[Applause]